Project six is the feed
reader testing project.
And after the map I gotta say that this
project is a lot less intimidating.
It's actually pretty straightforward and
fairly easy.
There's a few little gotchas in
there that you gotta be careful of
specifically with sort of
the asynchronous tests.
But overall, I think this project is
quite a bit easier than that because
you're really not starting from scratch.
You're starting from a project
that's been handed to you
that you need to write tests for so
then you can begin expanding on it more.
And believe it or not, I would say
this is pretty common that you might
get a piece of code or you're
working on a project and you someone
hasn't put time to add tests to it and
you're asked to write tests for it.
I know I'm pretty bad about
doing test-driven design myself.
I always implement the thing and
I'm like I should probably add
a test to check that in the future.
When you should be writing
the test first and
then implementing the tool or design or
whatever you're trying to do.
But specifically for
this project let's take a look at
what we're going to be given here.
So we're going to be given
this Udacity feed site.
Which is your standard RSS feed
with some articles from Udacity.
So you can go in and
read these articles.
It's actually pretty usable.
It's got like a little awesome
pop-out side navigation.
I mean, like I can follow his links and
it actually takes me to the blog.
So it's a pretty usable site and
it actually works really well.
But we need to actually add some tests
in here to make sure these things
stay working well.
When we want to add extra
functionality to it.
And as you can see on the bottom
here there's sort of this big
gray block section, and
this whole Jasmine symbol.
And this is sort of our test
suite inspector section.
So in this project we're going to be
using a testing suite called Jasmine.
And it's really awesome,
I really like it.
It makes writing tests really simple and
they're very readable way.
Like writing the test almost feels like
writing a sentence, which is fantastic.
And you can see here that
I'm not failing anything.
So I know the tests I've written
are working correctly, awesome.
But let's talk a little bit about sort
of what we're expecting for this project
and what might be some gotchas in
the rubric that we can clear up now.
So the first criteria we're looking for
is test coverage.
We're asking that the required tests for
the project are all provided and
are comprehensive enough to
adequately test the functionality.
This part should be
pretty straightforward.
Mike Wales went through a lot of
effort to make sure the comments were
very clear on what a functionality
you were trying to solve and
what we're looking for.
And so you should definitely
read the comments and
then work on what test
you want to create.
The sort of gotcha part I think
is in the exceed specification.
So if you're looking for your project
to really exceed what we're asking for.
We ask that students add additional
test beyond those required
that adequately tested additional
features within the application.
Student should provide documentation
within the review describing these
feature features.
One of the things we said
right in here that I think
students are a little like whoa
do I have to actually do this?
because you can actually write tests for
future features you plan to add.
So if there's something that you
don't like about RSS feed or
you can think of a way to improve it or
maybe there's some sort
of feed reader that you've seen
out there that you really like.
And there's some functionality that
you think would be really cool to add,
you can write a test for that.
And then we get the question back
all the time is, okay well do I
actually have to implement that or
do I just have to write the test for it?
And we're saying you only have
to write the test for it, but
in the readme please describe
what that feature would be.
What the test is looking for and
explain in a a little bit of detail
about how you might go
implementing that feature.
You don't have to implement it though.
But we would like you to have sort of
a clear idea of what that feature is,
what kind of test you
need to test it out with.
The next thing is test results.
And that's all required tests for
the project to passed.
This is pretty easy if you've written
all the tests excessively you should see
that when you load the project
that that Jasmine area
doesn't come up with any errors.
It's all going to be green, it's
going to say that all its specs passed.
That should be a pretty good indicator
that you're on the right track there.
As far as the exceeding
specifications for that section.
If student adds additional tests,
these tests are allowed to fail
as they may be testing for future
features that have not been developed.
So that goes back to,
do I actually have to create these?
No you don't.
It's okay if those ones fail as well
because these aren't features that
you've implemented yet.
The rest is pretty straightforward,
I mean code quality.
I think at this point you guys who have
read through the style guide plenty of
times or are already writing
code that's decently styled.
Comments right,
should be pretty straightforward
make sure you do comment your code.
And make sure to add comments if
you're doing anything really strange.
And then make sure to include
a Read Me with this project.
Especially if you're
looking to exceed and
you need to explain
those future features.
So one thing I always like to do
when demoing this project is kind
of show you how you can test to make
sure your specs are actually working.
So it's always nice when you
write a spec and is passing.
So it's really cool when your page looks
like this and everything is passing.
But you might be asking yourself
did what I do you actually work.
So an easy way that has that,
pop up in our terminal here and
open up our project,
is to break the project itself.
So if we look inside our [INAUDIBLE]
we
should see that we have a test
here that says that all the feeds
should be defined and all of the in
feeds.length should be zero.
In the test, what we're looking for
is that all our feeds are to be defined
and all feeds might possibly zero.
So let's figure out what all feeds are.
So if we look in at app.js file
will see that there's this variable
to defined called all feeds.
And according to our test spec we
are saying that this should be defined.
So let's just delete this and save and
go back to our tabs here and
refresh this to see what happens.
Gosh, so many failures.
But specifically we see that reference
error, all feeds is not defined.
So we can see that that is
breaking successfully and
we can see that right when we put it
back That that test is working properly.
It detected correctly that
allFeeds wasn't defined.
It also says that allFeeds
length shouldn't be zero.
So if we go in and have it defined but
have nothing it it,
we should see a bunch more failures.
And we can see that, right?
Expected zero not to be zero.
Now we can see that right.
That's part of our RSS feeds
are defined testing suite.
So let's go back and
fix that and we can se.
Cool, that's sort of being tracked or
that is being checked correctly.
So when you're writing your tests
it's good to kind of go through and
explore the app.js code a little bit.
And understand what the code is doing.
You can also write,
explore the actual app and
use the developer tools
to look at these files.
But I like looking at it and Sublime
catches this because really pretty.
[LAUGH] The same thing with the HTML,
I mean,
there's going to be a few
tests that you have to do to
look at specific HTML elements and
if certain classes are defined.
So be sure to go through the HTML and
make sure that.
You understand a little bit about
what the cite is doing that way you
can properly test it.
Right, it does no good to not,
either have a clear idea of what you're
implementing or
have a clear idea of what's implemented.
And then start writing tests
you need to start somewhere and
it's always good to kind of understand
the app that you've been given
before you get writing tests for.